بشكل جيد فيما يتعلق بما
يقولونه سواء السيد.  ظريف لا
يقول الحقيقة أو أنه ليس على علم
بما تفعله حكومته على
الجانب الآخر هو ما تعتقد
أنهما منقسمان برأيك. نحن نعلم أنه
لا يوجد جزء من الحكومة الإيرانية يعرض
صورة للرغبة.
للتحدث إلى العالم ولكن لا يبدو أن
لديهم أي تأثير وهناك جزء آخر
من الحكومة يريد
توسيع الثورة والسيطرة على المناطق
ولا يريدون التحدث ولذا
فهم مثل وجهين من  العملة نفسها
ومن من تقييمك من
الذي يفوز أنه في
الوقت الحالي في إيران لا يمكنني إثبات
ذلك لحقيقة ولكن ما يمكنني
رؤيته هو أن سلوك إيران العدواني
قد زاد ولم يقلل من
تهديدات إيران للمنطقة  وإلى جانب
إمدادات الطاقة العالمية لم
تنخفض ، لذا فإن المتشددين في
تصاعد يبدو الأمر كذلك ، فماذا
تريد أن تفعل إيران الآن وإذا كانوا
سياسيين هنا في نيويورك هذا الأسبوع
لا يمثلون الدولة فماذا يمكن
أنهم  هل نريد أن تتصرف إيران
كدولة طبيعية نريد أن تتوقف إيران عن
كونها ثورة وأن تكون دولة قومية
نريد أن تتوقف إيران عن التدخل في
شؤون الدول الأخرى
ودعم الجماعات الإرهابية
ونريدها أن تتوقف عن
تزويد الإرهابيين بالصواريخ البالستية؟  المجموعات ونريدهم
أن يتأكدوا من أنهم ليسوا في
وضع يسمح لهم أبدًا بامتلاك سلاح نووي ،
فنحن نريدهم أن يكونوا جيرانًا جيدين ،
ونريد أن تكون لدينا علاقات جيدة مع إيران ،
ونريد التجارة معهم ، لكن لا يمكننا فعل
ذلك إذا كان كل شيء  نحصل عليهم من الموت
والدمار على مدار 40 عامًا ، لقد
حاولنا مد يدنا
وصداقتنا للإيرانيين وكل ما حصلنا عليه هو الموت
والدمار والآن
سياستهم كبار سياسييهم الرئيس
روحاني وزير الخارجية ظريف
سيكون في الجديد  يورك ، ما هي قيمة
المحادثات التي يجرونها إذا كانوا لا
يمثلون البلد ، أعتقد أن
الإيرانيين بحاجة إلى سماع
رسالة موحدة وحازمة من المجتمع الدولي
مفادها أن هذا التصرف  vior غير
مقبول ويجب أن يتوقف هذا السلوك
، لقد سمعوا هذه الرسالة من قبل
، لم يسمعوا
أنهم بحاجة إلى سماعها بصوت عالٍ جدًا
ويجب أن يكون هناك
تهدئة مع إيران لا تعمل على
سبيل المثال محاولة ضبط  إن
نظام الدفع المالي الموازي هو استرضاء
يحاول منحهم حد ائتماني ، وهو
تهدئة
شجعتهم ، ويجب على الإيرانيين أن
يعرفوا أنه ستكون هناك عواقب
لأفعالهم ، تشعر إيفون
بضغط العقوبات بلا شك
وأنت تشعر  لقد أدت حرارة
ضغوطهم إلى هذا الهجوم على بلدك ،
إذا كنت على حق في أن إيران فعلت ذلك ،
فأنت تشعر بحرارة هذا الضغط ،
نعم ، لكننا لا ننخرط في الاسترضاء
، وسنفعل كل ما يلزم لحماية
بلدنا ومواطنينا.  وسكاننا ومنشآتنا
وسنعمل مع حلفائنا من أجل ضمان
حدوث ذلك ، هل نحن على
عتبة الرد العسكري ، هل
تعتقد أننا لا نريد الحرب نحن؟
لا يريد الحرب ،
لكن الأمر متروك حقًا للإيرانيين إذا
استمروا في الاستمرار على هذا الطريق ،
فإنهم يخاطرون بإمكانية
القيام بعمل عسكري ، لكن لا أحد يريد الحرب ،
الجميع يريد حل هذه المشكلة
سلميًا ، والنتيجة النهائية يجب أن تكون
وضع حد لسياسات إيران العدوانية.
لا أرى فرقًا في الوقت الحالي
إذا كنت لا تمانع في أن أقول إن إيران
تنتج هذه الأسلحة ثم
تنتظر تحقيقًا لمعرفة مكان
إطلاقها لأن كل ذلك بالتأكيد
يرقى إلى نفس الشيء الذي
أنت عليه  سوف نصل إلى نفس النقطة في
النهاية ، هل تحاول كسب الوقت
بالقول إننا نحقق في الوقت
الحالي عندما يكون لديك ميل قوي جدًا
لذلك نحن نحمل إيران المسؤولية
لأن الصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار التي
تم إطلاقها على الجراحة ليست كذلك  فقط
ضد الحفلة والمصفوفات ولكن أيضًا من
اليمن تم بناء صواريخ إيرانية من طراز إيراني ،
لذلك نحملهم
المسؤولية ولكن شن هجوم
من أراضيك إذا كان هذا هو الحال.
فئة مختلفة ما هي
الفئة المختلفة التي يمكن
اعتبارها عملاً حربياً